you're returning people are so excited
about this for this great television
project as obi-wan Kenobi yeah this is
gotta be very exciting it's exciting
it's exciting because I can finally say
that I'm doing it it's been years of
pretending but oh I don't know well
because I get asked all the time every
time I do an interview it always comes
up you know would you would you do it
again and there's all this speculation
and I had to just lie because they don't
that you know there's Studios and the
franchise they want to keep everything
secret tonight I understand that but it
comes down to me in a situation where
I'm having to actually lie to people say
well I don't know I would be up for it
if they ever want to do it and it's gone
for years now yeah we've been talking
about it for a long time but it started
looking like I'm sort of trying to talk
for the job like I was trying to get
there get the job as or be one again you
know at Disney's door say yeah yeah
would you you know I mean famously you
had to take over this role that was
immortalized by the great Alec Guinness
and you did this remarkable job and so
much time has gone by do you feel like
you're you're you're you're you're
getting closer yes and not even nearer
to the age that Alec Guinness facts when
he did it thank goodness yeah thank you
bless you Alec Guinness was I think he
140 when he but at least you've had more
life experience you didn't really play
him at a different period in life yes I
mean the most satisfying thing about
those films other than the some of the
fight sequences which were amazing to do
was was the study of Alec Guinness and
trying to trying to be believably him as
a younger man that was as an acting
challenge that was the most satisfying
thing about those movies and so now
that's the same except I'm just closer
to the age he was when he played that
film so it'll be interesting to to play
him now and also it being post you know
plot wise the three films that I made
already it's after that obviously so
there's a bit of there's a bit of story
plot there there's a nice Park yes--we
with I hope so
the you mentioned fight scenes
lightsaber battles yeah
can be difficult can't they when you're
doing them in real I mean when you're
when you're on set and you're doing a
lightsaber battle there are inherent
problems that people we're just used to
seeing lightsaber battles and yanking
like oh those look amazing but we don't
understand that technically there's some
problems there there they are incredibly
intricate to learn there first of all it
takes a long long time to learn the
choreography because they're essentially
like dances and you have because you are
actually whacking away at each other you
have to you have to be in the right
place at the right time or you get hurt
and occasionally you do you get the
lightsabers we we fight with our pole
their metal poles and they you know they
add the effect later later on but when
you're when you're fighting you're
fighting sort of full contact with each
other and so you have to learn them
which takes a long time and then when
you're doing them because you're sort of
full contact occasionally the the poles
are slipped down one another and on a
sword in the old days when we used to
use swords they had a hilt which would
stop the blade from coming down onto
your hands but lightsabers don't have
held yes as Jedi's you're not meant to
need one yeah what idiot what idiot
didn't put a hill a lightsaber you
should need those as well
you need a hilt every now and again
you'd get you know the blade would just
skitter down the other guy's blades
Hayden's blade over and get you right on
the knuckles and you'd have to take a
little minute away in the corner I would
love to see those out wouldn't you love
to see those out there many oh just
to see Darth Vader going like this just
so much so much fun it's true it's true
they were fun to do and there's a guy
whose job it is to just make lightsabers
that there was a guy on set and he had a
cart that was a lightsaber making cart
on wheels so it could be pushed to stage
three and then over to stage 5 and
because after every take the poles would
invariably get a bit bent and
occasionally you get a really good Bend
and then you know you really got a good
shot and you know but he his job was to
take your lightsaber after every take
and he'd be over in the corner on your
lightsabre and he'd bring it back over
but thank you my man good man yes I love
imagining here me in a pub telling
people what he does
straighten lightsabers is what I do yeah
so I'll be sleeping with you later I
just wonder where all the bent ones
ended up there must be a big lightsaber
bent Mountain somewhere in somewhere